[Music]
this fall
six
cities prepare
for two
rebels with a
[Applause]
[Music]
cause phoenix
houston
charleston national new york baltimore
the rebels with a car's comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
now for a trip inside trump worlds
even heads up we're going to need you
for the trio
okay thanks quarterback oh yeah and i
put some extra mushrooms on that swiss
there for you i know you like himself oh
thanks man i appreciate it
it made me wonder at the end of a long
week was was this a lie too
but this now the trump presidency this
is what a crisis of leadership looks and
feels a quarter block
every week another schedule would you
say you got these mushrooms again from a
fan this is from colorado rudy giuliani
you see him there on hannity this
weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
he's been behaving this way
jeez
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
waiting for the acts to come
corporations of shirt fake news bloody
lackey man i've been a nazi boy
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
tell me tell me tell me
[Music]
two
[Music]
are you feeling all right
same for doctor oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
oh that's that's a
delightful ship
good sip of tea i'm about to discuss uh
um hera today uh uh
mr bill moore a talentless hack
it's gonna be a day
that's if uh old johnny carson had to
address uh bill maher back in his day no
there'd be a guest on the show look we
have a lot to get to bill maher we've
talked about him for a while beware the
wolf in sheep's clothing he made the
mistake of letting this name this show's
name come out of his mouth so we have to
address it
and for everyone who thinks he's on your
side look i think it's important to kind
of note the timeline i think there are
people who do have a change of heart but
you need to know their flash of genius
what changed kind of like mitt romney
when he said i became pro-life
well what changed you were already
mormon
so
uh my question to you before we move on
we'll also be talking about salman
rushdie being attacked yeah the
mennonites
uh and uh more outrage over the left and
uh this is war right that they're saying
this rhetoric is what's leading the
violence against the fbi
got a whole hit list sorry montage hit
less figuratively of the left saying far
more egregious things actually calling
people to violence so my question to you
is who which of the leftist talk show
hosts can you stomach most is it bill
maher is it trevor noah is it stephen
colbert is it jimmy kimmel is it jimmy
fallon did samantha be
is it
who else are there other options
i mean i'm pretty much just run through
the whole gamut i don't know i mean
i hate to say it but so far bill maher
on your list
i would say jon stewart in his prime
stuart for sure oh john stewart is great
though yeah john stuart even david
letterman was great uh conan is
obviously more anyway you let me know
who you can stomach the most uh we'll be
getting to all that and more geraldine
is here you're doing well i'm doing well
how are you you're doing wearing a nice
shirt available.com absolutely and uh
the fastest man on his feet the quickest
wit in the west him and i are on tour
this fall in phoenix september 16th at
the arizona federal theater then uh
houston september 17th two shows that
weekend at the financial center
sugarland and then charleston west
virginia where nothing is there so if
you're 100 or 200 miles away drive in uh
october 8th at the coliseum dave landau
ahoy how are you i am okay i'm looking
forward to this today today's gonna be
fun now it's time for for us to lay down
a little thick okay
really what really people okay
[Laughter]
so first off salman rushdie as you all
know was attacked but there's some more
information that uh
you know you may not have necessarily
heard from the media but i don't really
think you needed to
because i think you can guess
who's behind this i warn you there's
obviously some disturbing footage friday
he was stabbed in the neck during a
lecture in new york in case you've
missed it here's a clip
[Music]
yeah i think this is a different angle
from the original footage it is yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
they caught him right yeah yeah yeah
they caught him i don't know how he was
allowed to get that close to the stage
and uh that's also why yeah when we do
our shows we have very specific
protocols with security the kind of
stage we use the distance from the stage
and uh a lot of people with the guns so
we know
he was interviewed the guy that they
caught i didn't realize that one said i
ran so far away did he get away
wow yeah yeah anybody think you're right
because i really also saying barbie girl
which was weird that just didn't seem
related though
unrelated just seems like something
that's
the insane lament so the attacker we now
know is 24 year old hadi matar polish
according to the european and middle
eastern intelligence uh officials they
said that uh matar had been in direct
contact with members of iran's islamic
revolutionary guard corps on social
media and that's just so you know
a branch of the iranian military founded
by the ayatollah khomeini so iran said
this has nothing to do with the iranian
government and then proceeded to blame
salman rushdie and his fans like it was
really it was his fault because he
shouldn't have said that we didn't do
anything but shouldn't have said any of
those things that we don't like should
have been in public either
yeah no choice here's the thing we don't
play by your rules this is the problem
the left is going why would you say
something that would affront them
because we don't care yeah we don't care
if it's against their islam we don't
follow islamic law we don't follow
sharia law and just like dr ben carson
whispered until i fell asleep he said
the koran is completely incompatible
with the constitution this is exactly
why this is a shock because it took
place in new york this takes place every
day across the islamic world and by the
way all the time in europe the only
place you're even remotely safe is the
united states if you speak out against
islam by the way i'm not a big fan
muhammad
serial rapist pedophile warmonger so
just last week also the uh another
member of the uh irgc because i don't
want to say iranian revolutionary guard
corps it's like the abbreviation is
still way too long yeah they were
charged with uh a plot to kill john
bolton
and uh justin completely unrelated news
well we remember covering this on uh i
think it was on tuesday or wednesday in
albuquerque there were islamic people
who were killed right and they were
suspecting white supremacy uh turns out
it was uh
actually a muslim himself no in
albuquerque what 51 year old named
muhammad sayed so he looks like he
should be white yeah well
he looks like he's wearing islamic face
yes he looks like he's the dad on happy
days terrorists like me that's it's
unhappy days well in cnn not for him
msnbc they could not get there fast
enough to say this is probably more
evidence of white supremacy in the
united states and we have to catch this
killer muslim shops were actually
closing down everybody was like oh my
gosh there's a mad white gunman on the
loose and there's like oh it's one of
ours and then nothing yeah then it's
like the calls coming from inside the
house exactly like oh
well so really as opposed to white
supremacy homegrown extremists it was an
imported actual terrorist
cool no word on a fact check from cnn or
uh you know any kind of uh retraction so
let me just do the math here this last
week we've seen a muslim attempt to
murder a writer for his opinions on
islam and rushdie a plot from one of
that same uh people's front liberation
of iranian no bikinis whatever it is
murder the former national security
adviser you know plot for it uh muslim
arrested for murdering other muslims
yeah it's basically gotten
almost no national coverage
and i think i'm figuring out
why it's
[Music]
white supremacy that's the problem that
we're facing right that's right number
one probably it's the number one
terrorist the number one terrorist i
just want to make sure are we all in
agreement you nailed it yeah it's white
supremacy correct
good and authors they're a big problem
authors are a big problem you know
particularly the people who wrote the
quran i think that sort of got stabbed
in and is going to lose their eyes but
the response of the left is like well
you shouldn't have provoked it right
yeah that's not how america works no
it's not freedom of speech where are you
on the well you shouldn't have dressed
like that yeah because it's the same
comments exactly same argument salman
rushdie was a little cleavage well yes
he did have a good bosom i didn't think
he was a little stabby i don't think you
can i don't think i'm not saying it's
justified i'm just saying it takes two
to terrorist tango by the way it's a
live show monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern in case this gets removed we
never know uh you can watch us on
youtube monday through thursday at 10
a.m eastern because the notifications
don't work but i recommend you watch on
rumble or of course on mug club where we
do an additional full hour of show yeah
monday thursday 10 a.m eastern don't
count on notification subscriptions we
have about 19 devices here set for
notifications yeah two i'm in i don't
get one yeah i don't know once in a
while i do and i think they do it just
to piss me off i would rather they be
consistent yeah hey youtube can you get
a notification for anyone who hits the
bell and wants one i don't want one okay
[Music]
now let's move on to elizabeth warren
our favorite
i don't know why she's allowed to
yeah zero parts cherokee yes i have more
subs in here in african than she has
cherokee yes but she wrote a book on it
i've had a cherokee so i'm more indian
than her that's true yeah and native
sorry in it and yours was grand what is
it
she said something against ted cruz and
ted tweeted back like this isn't even
one one thousand twenty-fourth percent
true
and then she started shaking you know
like the father-in-law at a wedding
dance she always moves like this dad
hired an intern to get his uh twitter
you know a little more
that's the only reason she can't be a
dictator because hitler wouldn't have
been taken seriously if he moved like
this no no be like okay he has rickets
we'll
they would have just committed him in
those like she's one of those muppet
guys who says yep just yet
the first day on sesame street yeah
exactly
we'll show you some clips you'll see
that's exactly right i don't do a bill
my impression but this is elizabeth
warren pretty much is she's like the
used car thing that just the air thing
just keeps blowing all over the place
all right
i'll leave it tell we need to get to the
story an olivettelli's new tell-all book
about elizabeth warren and you can
comment below if you think she's the
most just
inherently unlikable not the one you
dislike personally but the most
inherently unlikable of all the people
who run for office
there's a book
from ali
i also put that on the watch list
lamented the misogyny
of the democratic party this is actually
a quote where elizabeth warren said
everyone comes up to me and says i would
vote for you if you had a penis
everyone everyone comes up to her and so
you know here's the thing she might have
credit where she might have a point
which is why here in the show we've
actually spared no expense we've
consulted with our experts for our new
segment um the electability test
[Music]
yeah
and we have a computer that actually
creates algorithms so we can look at
different possible electability
scenarios right yeah yeah and we ran
thousands of scenarios through our
algorithm to see if elizabeth warren
would in fact be more electable if she
had um you know she had a penis
partial penis whatever it is
and we were able to create that
hypothetical scenario the machine that
we have created for you today this is
what uh we would see if she were running
for president as a man
it's a rhino a unicorn
yakuza's thinking her head's a seat
so elect you know what i will say though
there is something there
i do feel that i would be more likely to
vote for her i i mean just for this year
like i would i would like to see more of
her speaking in public but be hilarious
you'll see hold on a second let's bring
this back up uh what do you think there
dave do you think i think that she is
an attention grabber i think she's more
i can see what her she has a point can
you put a hat on that uh
yeah she does have a point i mean it
have to be like a have like a mongolian
war hat something like that that will
still give you monkey pox by the way
just fyi yeah yeah well if you look at
it wrong you can get monkey pox i don't
know i would give her probably a 20
increase in electability i would give
her a raise in pay yes
yeah no matter where she works yeah yeah
it's probably 30 pay um
i'd stir some pow wow with it yep oh
geez i agree it's like a pestle for if
you have a good mortar and pestle
yes it is she could pass all her way to
a general i don't know how she do with
the electoral college but we can just do
away with that all right you guys let us
know below this has been our
electability test
okay people always tell me like i'd bang
you if you had a vagina so i know the
feeling yeah yeah yeah yeah put it right
on your forehead what do you think the
odds are that anyone one person has
actually ever said that to her
what are the chances what are the odds i
think her husband said it to her well
that's not the question the question is
what are the odds that everyone has said
it too well i know i'm just i'm making
it harder steve yeah i'm tying a hand
behind my back a little bit yeah i don't
know everyone she's ever met yeah
everyone's never met nobody would say it
like that they'd be like oh if you were
a man i would vote for you maybe i could
see that i still doubt that but like hey
if you had a penis i'd vote for you yeah
like like one of our supporters is
showing up at a beto conferences if you
had a penis then you would have my vote
but since you don't it's out of my hand
yeah i just don't know what to do maybe
it's funny you mother effort no she
doesn't help her she does what the brian
uh she does what uh donald trump does
versus you know everyone always tells me
i would never say this they say you're
the best looking man that's what they
say and i say well look i wouldn't go
that far but they say that's what they
tell me
but we no one says that's serious no
he's like he's he's bullshitting with
her they're writing a book about it and
it's serious yeah called if i had a
penis by elizabeth warren
penis like me had a penis only i had a
penis and you scarecrow
like the cowardly lion only instead of a
pendant she gets a dildo and you don't
know
we'll get a penis that wasn't going to
rape you
so we have to put the dog to sleep which
one is it they all point to elizabeth
warren
here's some blankets
so uh we have a lot to talk about today
first before we get to bill maher we do
want to play a clip of bill maher
because it does sort of lead this
segment and i want you to comment below
have you agreed with this idea of
disbanding the fbi
have you agreed with the idea that it's
time to defund these intelligence
communities in the irs sometimes we see
people on the right saying that's
extremist we don't need that kind of
extreme how is it extremist to say
people who are acting completely outside
of the law with no real oversight
because they are the law they're judge
dreading this you know what we need to
uh hold them accountable i don't see it
as extremist
you guys can comment below because i'm
not gonna if you want me to stop saying
it i'm not gonna
but bill maher led this with this
talking point that comes directly from
media matters
does that camera work no okay
okay
i won't wake up i get that it's monday
morning for crying out loud
also how is that so far away from your
camera thing you have to reach over like
you're crossing the wall of china for
chronology
okay yeah so bill maher led it with his
talking point it did come from media
matters and was disseminated through cnn
msnbc huffington post then cnn again
four days late because brian stelter had
to get on the action he only has one
slot per week
bill maher decided to uh take a jab and
you know look it's all in good fun but
uh
i'd prefer if it were funny and his
audience didn't really think so either
here he is discussing uh this show and a
tweet
now all across the right-wing media it's
war they're literally using this word
civil war war
what's that a right-wing podcaster i
think the name is stephen crowder said
sleep well
tomorrow is war
and then tomorrow came and there was no
war
unless by war he means more podcasting
yeah war
that crowd animator is the most valuable
man in showbiz absolutely you're right
there joe you can't lose them
okay let's go to this here's the thing
with that yeah here's the issue is look
i've talked about this before they want
to try and make it seem as though the
verbiage of war by the way this guy
hopefully you have the camera there tim
yeah uh
this guy andrew breitbart you know i
tweeted out a gif of good lord to a man
tweeted out a gif of him saying war as
well when you talk about war against the
media you're just
[Laughter]
so the left has been trying to say that
if you say and this is the thing they
want you to be afraid to use terminology
like world look how often do you hear
not only not only politicians not only
uh p public figures but you hear
athletes we're going to war right when
you were doing food if you're playing
football we're going to war this weekend
here political war war in the middle
class it's something that's been used
for a very long time however the left
tries to do the slate of hand and they
try and make it seem as though
republicans conservatives you are
constantly calling for actual wars and
if you don't believe me believe your
lion eyes and ears here we go
50 years ago this country launched a war
on poverty can't they work
has it worked and i'm not talking about
the wars in afghanistan or iraq or the
instability in the middle east
i am talking about the war being waged
in america today most notable is judge
michael ludwig who will say in his
testimony that president trump and his
allies instigated a war on democracy the
republican party declared war on
democracy on january 6 i mean the idea
that there was a war room that was
overseeing what was going on we're going
to war room is literally six you gotta
coordinate absolutely chilling uh and if
there ever was a situation
a war on what a war on us that's right
our democracy they simply cannot or will
not recognize that 30 years ago the
republican party declared war on them
and war on democracy itself after this
quick break we'll review the
relationship outcome conservative war on
education why
is my question
why has the gop picked schools as the
battleground to fight these culture war
issues because this week tennessee has
become ground zero in the conservative
war on education
you've covered
declared warning
is trump just using this as a shield
this culture war i will say uh you know
in your opening segment um professor
bridges showed a very effective counter
to
um
a culture war issue in her testimony
again men in black his head grew back
after a major trigger waging an all-out
war for power and we're seeing uh the
latest antics uh are made clear that
they are at war with mickey mouse this
is a award
that has been going on for over 20 years
and longer than that republican
legislatures are waging a war on women
all women comedians at least it's not
the erection i've been under attack for
quite some time and i need to stick up
for my tribe this war on jokes must end
well honestly and that's way more
incendiary because he just also instead
of tribalism he invokes tribalism i need
to i need to stand up for my truck okay
war on jokes oh right
outside of this that's you you're waging
a war on jokes outside of it's it's not
funny drop the the hiroshima bomb
you didn't know it's funny
outside of it being not funny i was
pissed because i was just like i looked
down i'm like he basically just gave you
a hard time for everybody other than him
and democrats and libs knowing what you
meant everybody knew that that wasn't an
actual call for ward right we woke up
the next morning and there's no warning
like yeah we weren't calling for
violence because you would have been
really mad if there was actual violence
true yeah most of the the operators on
our and by the way that's why just got
paid to just slap it together yeah he's
gonna be honest guys he's like slap my
name on there with ben affleck with
goodwill hunting wow so not to mention
you see that the war rhetoric where they
say that the republicans conservatives
have been declaring war on women for 30
years i mean i was still i was still
playing with my teddy ruxpin so that
couldn't have been me but now they're
saying that i'm the one who's declaring
warren you're the one declaring where
it's not just that i said it i said
something that all of you are saying
obviously there's nothing necessarily
original there of invoking um the
analogy of war
that's obvious okay but here's something
else the leftists of course have made
far more and very recently egregious
blatant public calls to active violence
believe you're lying eyes and ears
opiate voice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go to the hill today
get up and
please
get up in the face of some congress
i want to tell you gorsuch i want to
tell you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind
and you will pay the price you cannot be
civil with a political party that wants
to
destroy
what you stand for what you care about
ah so the republic even there she sort
of tacitly acknowledged the
conservatives want to destroy what they
stand for yes largely communism but then
said you cannot be civil and of course
we had kamala harris saying they
shouldn't stop they should continue to
write this is so funny this is the first
time uh there's been this kind of call
to violence uh against uh our men are
men in blue first off you're the fbi
you're not our men in blue okay
conservatives have supported their local
law enforcement they have a problem with
federal overreach it's entirely
consistent with the concept of
federalism we believe in states rights
before federal rights especially when
there's no oversight and by the way this
isn't unprecedented for more proof check
out the summer of love and four billion
dollars in damages and thousands of
arrests and casualties yeah and they're
basically blaming us for what they
thought donald trump did when he said
your rhetoric is what caused january 6.
well look at the rhetoric that you guys
just had and look at the damage that we
just talked about it was very literal
people were harassed in diners and then
of course when they docked the supreme
court justices people were protesting at
their houses violently and that's
obvious we knew that that was going to
happen when you get in their faces and
let them know that they can't be
anywhere in public what do you think is
going to happen
that's exactly what's going to happen
protest fine that's different that isn't
make sure they know they're unwelcome at
the gasoline station oh that was a
rhetorical question yeah see i've been
watching too much bill maher i've lost a
sense
yeah you got it okay there we go all
right
and we'll literally play because pierce
morgan was on bill maher's show and
pierce morgan said have you ever seen a
happy vegan and he's like yes
and he goes i always say they're always
mad they're always hangry no no okay
that's not true okay that's not true
tell me he's a vegan no he's like a
vegetarian but he just like come on
you're supposed to be a comedian don't
step on it that's not true there are a
lot of good vegans okay people
all right so let's get to bill maher
here uh and i'd love for you to comment
below because i see a lot of people on
the right saying hey he's turning toward
the right
maybe on some issues and i want to be
clear a lot of people it's a cop out
when people say i didn't leave the left
the left left me no they didn't this is
the same party as it's been really since
it can certainly go back to carter to
today maybe jfk might be different
because jfk would be considered a
moderate republican today the
republicans have actually just become a
little more moderate and the left has
maybe gone more left but the truth is
the democratic party has consistently
been
remarkably left and certainly since the
last since 2009 certainly since barack
obama so people now peeling off like the
bill mars of the world no actually this
is the monster that you created and i
really think they need to sleep in the
bed that they made i'm not going to
bring anyone over to our side who's just
trying to go to where the money is
because their ratings are in the crapper
so uh let's get to bill maher
a little bit here and i look
it was an aside yeah i wish it were
funnier i'm glad that he addressed the
show it's kind of it's fine i don't
really think that he thinks we're trying
to take anyone to war i think his
writers and producers give it to him and
he's phoning it in
but this little prick just goes where
the money is
and his hot takes aren't even
necessarily edgy i think we have a
montage of him throughout the years
right that is not the
key party what happened what was the
origin of the tea party five years ago
it wasn't about bailouts sure it was it
was not it was about a mortgage bill and
then it was about obamacare it was about
about the stimulus it was about a black
president but let's let's let's
oh there he is accusing the right of
being racist
but they're not the same they're not gun
crazy they're not violent crazy who goes
to gun shows
who was for the war in iraq and i would
never say that all republicans are
racist
but if you are a racist and you're
looking for a political party
this is the obvious choice the mouse
trap at least right they hate they hate
being called racist conservatives but
isn't denying racism itself a form of
racism pouty
skinned hysterical and just not that
bright does that sound like anyone
we know today your last clip
[Applause]
oh
all right and finally new rule you can't
demand that everyone stand for the flag
if you've colluded with a foreign
government to subvert the very russian
people
that flag represents finally new rule
the party of reagan has to explain how
it has become the party of putin
while real time was on our break last
month the infamous p-tape
was finally found it's a high-definition
video of a press conference in helsinki
and and it's irrefutable evidence of a
russian hoe and his name is donald trump
so here's the thing i like it when
people sort of if they are now awakened
not woke but awakened but he where's the
flash of genius he went for years on
tyra's accusing everyone all of you
anyone who voted republican not just
conservatives of being racist
right and then even use the leftist
tactic of isn't denying racism
in and of itself
okay racism no no it sounds like it
isn't isn't denouncing the nazis isn't
that in and of itself a form of being a
nazi not at all
it's the laziest kind of argument that
he would use for years what did we have
we have republicans are all racist the
tea party is racist you can only oppose
barack obama if you're racist if you're
a gun owner you're a dummy we had donald
trump russia right we had all of this
stuff and then now he only once the
ratings are not doing nearly as well and
i think especially when he noticed he's
tried to go off on his own which we'll
get to in a second with this podcast
decided he was against those views and i
i hate to use the word grifting i i
think
i just don't know how genuine it is i'd
love to have him on bill i know you're
watching to talk about it because now
he says this
okay but if putin thought trump was
really that supportive of him
why didn't he invade when trump was in
office
it's at least worth asking that question
if you're not locked into one
intransigent thought well then get in
your delorean [ __ ]
because putin was intimidated by him
yeah has he has he come out and said oh
hey i was wrong no no that's the issue
nobody does no
you absolutely should because these
thought like all of those clips played
together like these have to be this has
to be somebody who doesn't care or
really have a a moral center or or maybe
an ideological center he's just like you
said going where the money is because
they completely contradict each other
yeah and it's not like we're taking
clips from like 55 years ago and
comparing to today right like you can
have that moment like you said but we
don't see the moment where he's like hey
i was wrong about all these things and
now he's saying so if i came out
tomorrow and i was pro-abortion all the
way up until birth uh you know including
after after birth period right and i
support the virgin you'd say i have some
questions if i came out and i said i
endorsed bernie sanders you would have
some questions rightfully so i wouldn't
be allowed to just continue on down the
trail and act like like i had always
been in that camp
and i just think that people if they're
coming over they need to have some some
questions asked them like carrie lake
last week on the show i said look you
were a democrat at one point why she
just because i was very anti-war and i
thought the mccain was sort of being
from arizona another side of the same
coin with george w bush barack obama i
thought they were both liberal barack
obama was the most likely to end the
world she answered the question yeah
so this is what bill maher did and now
let's let's listen to him again when he
talks about this uh this podcast the
podcasting just in case you've forgotten
so now all across the right-wing media
it's war they're literally using this
word civil war war
there's a right wing
i think her name is stephen crowder said
sleep well
tomorrow is war
and then tomorrow came and there was no
war
unless by war he means more podcasting
yeah
look and i get it he's on hbo podcasting
is silly right you you'd never have
anything to do with that bill maher
oh that's right just whoops just really
badly all of a sudden without those hbo
dollars and re-running four times a day
it's a little bit tough to get those get
those ratings numbers are a little low
there yeah and you know what the truth
is i wouldn't because war i mean
you might want to check your comments
section there and of course keep it
simple everybody yep baby
but i wouldn't want to hurt bill maher's
feelings
kyle kalinski he does a great impression
of you
i i didn't didn't know who he was have
you ever seen the face-off the face swap
version that he does of you
on instagram no oh i don't know find
that before we leave what's that
did i say kalinski sorry
[Laughter]
he's got your face and he's doing an
impression of you you've never seen this
did not i saw what anyway the point yeah
it doesn't matter the point was what was
the point
[Laughter]
they're both high but i just like that
joe is so
aware of being functional well he's just
laughing he knows you can laugh at
yourself yeah that's what's i do find
that odd in that clip and but we'll be
taking your impressions on uh mug club i
think at some point we're doing some
joke
people viewers will submit some jokes
later on oh okay that'll be fun yeah
yeah and uh here's the thing we didn't
just podcast just to be clear the war
that's not what happened we called
republicans to the mat by the way the
war was really more so wage and
republicans i said by two o'clock today
if you do not actively call for
disbanding of the fbi i will not support
you i will actually come out against you
like him as a person dan crenshaw you
got some explaining to do yeah ted cruz
when he was on we were like hey section
230 coming up section 230 right now ted
cruz has been pretty uh strong from what
i've seen in the fbi issue though yeah i
bought a rambo bandana did you yes wow
well and i realized it wasn't literal i
decided to just sweat the deal he didn't
buy a rambo bandana he took it off of
his a commemorative gizmo that's true
gremlins two irons true the new batch
don't you dare
mansplain gizmo to me i didn't mansplain
kismodeo i was just saying i preferred
uh gremlins too when i was a kid and
then when i rewatched it i was like this
is not good no it's a rough rough movie
so we we called the republicans of the
mat with the uh the fbi including kerry
lake likely future governor yeah of
phoenix and this is one thing too
arizona sorry of arizona she's from
phoenix but uh of arizona yes i know i
but you can you know admonish me here
look bill maher's never gonna admit that
he's wrong i said phoenix yeah i should
have said arizona well i think she lives
in phoenix now to be true
it doesn't matter there's no governor of
phoenix
okay
look i screwed up people people make
mistakes okay
and i don't do a bill more impression
kyle dunnigan does we can get him on the
show he does a fantastic impression it's
not one that i do
do not compare anything that we do here
today with cal dunigan's impression of
bill maher it's unbelievable
and you don't see this a lot with people
on the left this is where the right you
sort of we sort of devour our own people
say why don't you do more well look
we do as much as we no one expects jimmy
kimmel to change the laws in the country
immediately no one expects that of jimmy
fallon or even trevor noah but being
able to call republicans to the mat not
to mention by the way all of the pending
lawsuits with big tech which you're well
aware of and i can't discuss in full
hey bill maher how many of those have
you waged against the establishment are
you working along with hbo who half the
time copy they might copyright this
video so it gets removed just like
stephen colbert so they can eliminate
criticism of bill maher who has a tough
time you know tough time filling
filling seats in theaters and has a
tough time getting people listening to
his podcast when it's not on hbo
i understand why you'd want to hang on
to his his slice of the pie there and
also uh which clip do we have coming up
which clip is this i'm trying to
remember
from bill maher do we know
well i'm not sure there's another clip
is this the takes that he doesn't like
he has he has a take that he basically
wouldn't allow in a show is that what it
is oh let me see let's see what the next
clip is a short clip yeah appropriating
sounds like an unforgivable sin until
you remember that's what acting is
that's why acting jobs are called roles
and isn't the best acting always about
making us feel our common humanity
beyond separate identities why don't we
just go by merit and let the best actor
win you know it's so funny that he
mentions this because i have to talk
with
half asian bill about single party dual
party because his booker may have been
in new york or california where you know
they're not free but uh they reached out
to me was it 2017 that beauty and the
beast did the remake i think it was
2017. it was a year then here is going
to be like yeah yeah yeah yeah they have
that well you know what yakuza has a
commemorative uh that's true
and i was speaking with the booker at
bill maher
and uh and i have all this uh somewhere
or maybe i don't if it's not if you're
not allowed i don't yeah let's say you
don't yeah
and i remember them asking me the booker
at bill maher uh they said what do you
think about the donald trump russia uh
issue when i said uh what do you mean
so what do you think about the colluding
with russia i said oh my god is he
colluding with russia
i said well you know that's what uh
that's what people believe and you know
with the is there new evidence that i
didn't know about it so no i just want
to know i said oh so you want me to
speculate on something that is likely
untrue but for which there's certainly
no evidence it's not really what i do so
what i did find funny is i saw beauty
and the beast the live-action one the
other day and i think it was yesterday
and i do find it funny that oscar so
white is trending when mary j blige
played an armoire slash queen in white
face in 1740 slavery france so you know
maybe they came out even on that one she
goes oh so you want to talk about disney
i said no i'm talking about the woke
brigade cancel culture over the oscars
and they don't acknowledge that it goes
both ways a dollar a dollar short and a
day late for bill maher same views now
and by the way of course i was never on
the program which well which i think you
should be i mean honestly i think that
the that you and bill could have a very
interesting discussion he's never had
dennis miller on he's never had a
mcdonald's he's never had nick apollo on
he never had bill burr never had patrice
on geraldo he did have joe rogan on once
and chastised him for fear factor
because he bill maher was offended at it
that's how you know it's good because he
ruined american culture yeah
okay having people eat pig testicles
what come on that's gross i didn't even
know that was a challenge
last tuesday
it's two for one bowl testicle tuesday
lamb fries yes i'm a winner and here's
the thing with bill maher look
even his own you've talked about this i
know you've you've found him funny in
the past i have i found a lot of
politically i'm not yeah i don't want to
lie about it like i found a was a lot of
politically correct and funny i found
some of his specials funny have you seen
this new special i did not i said some i
texted you i remember i think we were in
uh where were we we were in colorado
springs and i was watching i remember my
hotel room that you have to tune into
hbo and watch the new special adulting
that's what it's called as it might have
been yeah yeah and you were like i'm not
gonna do that yeah
i knew where he was at
well with with bill i think there is a
genuine part of him when it comes to
comedians where he is defending it
because that's what he is but i think it
is definitely angled at his own speech
not necessarily the speech of every
comic exactly wait wait wait wait
whereas we have consistently defended
the speech of every comic we don't like
did you just call bill a comedian
he's a he's a comedian he's a comedian
i'm not don't do that that's lazy no no
no no it's not like listen i'm making it
doesn't matter you may not find him
funny but he's a comedian no i didn't
realize it's a fair joke how he came up
right now he's he's styling himself as a
political commentator who does a quick
little stand-up
right before his show and he goes and
talks to people
he was a comic in the 80s i'm not saying
that's what you do you got in tour you
just said in a nice way exactly what
norm said we said yeah you know yeah
guys i'm not like a political guy you
know and you have a yeah like bill maher
on there with uh you know uh uh what's
the name of the guy when the nobel
pulitzer will uh gosh will will what's
his name the uh i'm trying to remember
the conservative commentator i don't
know sitting there bill maher talking
with you know
uh talking with uh like uh
thomas uh thomas soul you know like
what's this guy gonna add right
you know i don't anything but he didn't
know anything either but you know he
makes it seem like i know something
there so i'm basically the everyman in
this conversation and i never looked at
bill maher as a comedian i looked at him
as somebody who hosted a show and tried
to be funny by the way watch the show
today to see what he said about us and i
was like this is very unfunny and i'm
not just saying like for massive you
know like
big comedian fans i'm saying for the
general audiences i would have to be
well here's where i will give you i will
give you uh some credit here i'll give
you some some points words too um
with crowd animators his own audience
often
finds him
not good that's actually something that
republicans reacted like they do in
karachi when someone burns a koran
karachi's in pakistan sorry i thought
you knew that they did not information
that shouldn't be out there that trump
has trump supporters like no this is
politically motivated they say if you
lock him up how how are we going to lock
her up
[Laughter]
that was kind of funny that one was kind
of funny but here's the thing i think
and they don't laugh because it's not on
the side of the politics exactly bothers
me so much about it like why always side
with that he's like kurt cobain you know
minus the talent that he's mad at his
audience for wanting him to play
something that he doesn't want to play
anymore
mine is a good wife
eventually yeah i never know one of
these days so here's the thing and i'd
like for you to comment below i think i
think that you always have to beware
charlatan's in your midst and by the way
they also come in the shape of people
who claim to be republicans that's why
we've waged our war just as much against
conservatives against republicans as we
have against liberals bill maher right
now i see a lot of people who share some
segments from this show and not aware of
the exact segment before that where he
was supporting the raid on donald trump
this guy wants to have it both ways he
has to play ball for the networks and
then when he tries to do his own podcast
which is really just him getting high
with semi interesting guests and then
some really interesting guests it falls
flat on its face he can't make it work
on his own and he's always a day late a
dollar short matt was the one who said
that which brings us to uh the formulaic
bill maher jokes bill maher's top seven
plus one hot takes this week seven plus
one
[Music]
this is seven plus one hot takes from
bill maher i think this is the wrong
document i don't think it says what no
i think i have it right you tell me as i
go out here without a net and there we
go i think this is just these seven plus
one jokes you would write well it's
still it's a hot take okay look okay
number seven
new rule okay ancient egyptian people
the son is not a god named ra okay it's
an effing ball of gas and not the kind
that you get from too much swarmer okay
shawarma's a it's a middle eastern dish
i thought you knew wait i didn't know
that is a spot-on joke you would use
that is absolutely okay this is our
seven plus one bill more hot takes you
know what uh dave give us number six
give us your best bill martha i'll try
kids uh here's a gentle reminder okay
the easter bunny
not a giant bunny hiding eggs in your
backyard it's your effing parents they
never should have had you in the first
place grow up you're five okay
[Laughter]
okay a good portion of these i feel like
they could have been taken from his
really taken from his show
yeah we were really trying to write
these and what he would write
seven plus one bill maher hot takes or
bill maher jokes however you wanna same
thing uh i said it wrong
do number five all right
all right somebody tell thomas jefferson
to keep his quill pen and his knickers
and out of the help okay oh boy oh jeez
i like brown sugar just as much as the
next guy but i wear something a little
more effective than sheep intestine okay
i don't know why you started doing it
like that lady in the health
yeah i was gonna say this is a terrible
because you sound like a flamboyant
southern man yeah well
you sound like you sound like the soul
octavia spencer ate yeah like zack
elephant is doing the
doing the effeminate races he's wearing
his fanny pack
all right
seven plus one hot bill maher takes
number four
listen donald trump is crazy okay
so crazy his tailor
his tailor
i can't okay his tailor had his jacket
fitted for a 44 crazy
[Laughter]
where the applause sign goes off yeah
it's a lot harder when you have a crowd
the segment is tough to do
it's tough because we're writing
accurate unfunny jokes and this is how
the reaction probably would be yeah
literally these would be useful in the
show i'll give you a okay i'll do number
three okay uh okay listen melania as you
know from russia mail order bride okay
it's no secret uh
she's the only wife who comes with the
question do you want fries with that
okay
[Laughter]
what
no one eats fast food all vegans
seven plus one hot takes from bill maher
[Laughter]
and by the way this is more effort than
he puts into his podcast number two dave
new rule america oh i like the girls to
read
all right rural america a bunch of mega
folks accidentally went to a lady gaga
concert saturday uh because they thought
the gaga stood for
getting a man
getting
hidden america
good again
right come on am i okay right
right the applause sign is late there's
there's a circuit
to put that on yeah i i'm not nice to
the hell someone someone fired my
animator okay let's replace him with one
of my black prostitutes that's not hard
i don't need an opener
i
really really don't
seven plus one number one bill more hot
takes look joe biden now is so old
people have started a new meme in his
honor okay
they've started a new meme in his honor
it's the kick the ice bucket challenge
okay
wait i have to plank
kick the bucket means dot okay it means
look okay he's old he'll die okay
whatever yeah okay
hbo i blame hbo all right and the final
uh seven plus one bill more hot takes
the plus one
dave why don't you take the plus one
they're saying trump might not be able
to run in 2024 after the mayor largo
seizure okay not a raid the only thing
trump uh looks like he's been running
for is a drive-through right
what's your necktie size
lasso okay
okay
[Laughter]
i pay for sex all right everybody stop
telling me dynamite this has been this
week's seven plus one
[Music]
oh this is the most uncomfortable i've
ever been on my own show i am so glad
you didn't come back to me for any more
i know
by the way you can share the show if
you're watching this uh of course on
youtube right now hit the share button
sharing is caring you can like it
all of those things help with the
algorithm you know the main issue here
is you don't have to acknowledge uh that
someone is funny but you can acknowledge
that it's a joke yeah and i can kind of
acknowledge that with with bill maher
that a lot of what he says is meant to
be funny but he's just so thin skinned
and he's so remarkably inconsistent and
this is a guy who look let me just tell
you one thing we've talked about this
there have been of course multiple
offers for me to do something similar if
we wanted to leave this and go to
network television that's why i
recommend i ask or don't that you sign
up lightweightcredit.commodclub
we do less than one percent of
advertising throughout this show
compared to about 10 or 15 with other
shows crazy we don't have to play ball
with a place like hbo we have to play
ball with a place like fox news and you
never fully know if you're getting the
fair
if you're getting the fair shake if
you're getting the real scoop from these
people because there are too many other
intermediaries i don't know maybe bill
maher would like to have one of you guys
or myself on the show maybe he would
come on this show but i guarantee you
his bookers won't allow him to they're
like it's like mickey protecting rocky
from mr t they don't want to let that
happen invite us on the show
look okay
you have to go through the process
you're not as funny as
bill you know tommy laren okay you know
all right you're no esee cup okay
you're no random author yeah you know
fred durst all right
no he's great
this is what he does he has people on he
does have uh you know he's had jordan
peterson of course i'm not saying he
only has people who are pets but that's
not worried about a comedy contest no
exactly honestly that's the only time
that i have seen clips of bill maher
never
never has been the front of the show
where he does the stand-up stuff it's
always been clips of him talking with
people and it's usually
i don't know it's it's not my style like
it feels like um what was the other guy
we just mentioned that was actually a
good liberal commentator just forgot his
name john stewart john stewart so it
feels like a dumbed-down version of jon
stewart where it's not as funny it's not
as quippy and it's not nearly as as as
kind of insightful well there's an
authenticity to jon stewart yeah yeah
yeah
i don't agree with john
yeah i don't agree with a lot of what he
says but i i get that he actually fully
believes it and is better at presenting
it no of course and i'm not like taking
a dump on bill maher i'm just like i
he's
no character like his ever appeals to me
he's like a curmudgeon right he's always
somewhat unhappy mopey and he just
throws something out there and it's
supposed to be funny
you're not a curmudgeon
is that me i think no
okay
you do realize where you're sitting
right
just one i'm just one step short of
pissing in jars in my compound you're
you're going after somebody like that a
rant is different than all right guys
this is stupid you're not doing that no
i think it's important look it's
important to like there are people like
louis black funny john stewart funny
yeah kathleen madigan funny you have a
lenny bruce shirt on right now lenny
bruce early stuff funny late stuff
absolutely terrible i don't care what
anybody says that's because the and i
agree but that's because like even the
in the picture
they decided to destroy him he became a
morphine addict and it was somebody who
stood up for free speech i mean yeah
that's a sad thing david letterman was
the funniest to me late night host who's
ever existed i know he's left conan
o'brien obviously very funny he's leaned
left so i don't have a problem with that
to be clear and i think that you
shouldn't have a problem with it look i
feel confident enough i recommend that
you go and watch bill maher's podcast go
watch the clips that we'll show we'll
probably continue it on mud club here a
little bit but go watch his podcast on
youtube go watch it see what you think
how about new
by the way we're going to make him
yakuza for a full 48 hours we're going
to have an electrode uh attached to him
where if he speaks for 40 hours he'll be
shocked he can only talk through that
sound board like stephen hawking yeah
right and i bet you he'll be very
effective at communicating oh i can't
right he's so quick with it it's unreal
but here's the thing there's a
difference between acknowledging that
someone is funny or talented and
bringing them and welcoming them in
amongst your ranks i think you need to
be prudent about that because we've seen
too many times people do that and then
just like a bull in a china shop and not
in a good way just cause a bunch of
damage there's a difference between
people you respect and you can hold at a
respectful distance versus people who
you allowed to put on your team jersey
and i just want to be clear about this
look all references are available at
louderwithcredit.com you can watch the
montages you can watch the original
clips that we've we've posted here today
just look at the timeline and i my main
question is always this whether it's
bill maher
whether it's anyone from uh one of these
you know youtube shows that became more
conservative anyone who says oh i've
changed you can look at a guy like
strzok and he explains why
uh you can look at a guy like reuben
okay and he explains why you can look at
someone like carrie lake who was always
a republican but was a democrat for
about four years and explained why
but there needs to be a flash of genius
moment let me ask you this anytime that
you've fundamentally changed your
worldview or there's been a
life-altering decision that you have
made
think about it
it could be when you decided you were
going to talk to your parents again it
could be when you decided you were going
to be a conservative as opposed to a
liberal it could be when you decided
that you know what you're going to go
back to school a fundamental course
altering of your life
guarantee you you can remember the
moment where you were when you made that
decision and what changed
it's actually a legal term there's a
great documentary on it called flash of
genius the guy who invented the
intermittent wiper uh greg kinnear plays
it yeah what is bill maher's flash of
genius that is my question so before we
bring someone into the fold
i think we always need to ask okay not
in a general the left left me no what
was the moment where you said oh my gosh
i'm going to be consumed by the monster
that i created and by the way bill maher
did create this monster this is a guy
who was on a campaign to portray all
conservative voters all republicans all
all tea partiers all people who oppose
barack obama as racists as
fundamentalists as extremists and this
is a guy who pushed and was complicit
with the russia collusion hoax from the
beginning and now tries to distance
himself from it and i can also tell you
behind the scenes that his bookers were
pushing the guests to discuss that hard
that's why
i was unceremoniously not invited on the
show could also be that you know i just
sucked in the interview process i have
no idea
but i do know they were asking for my
opinion on that and they didn't like
when i said you know what come on let's
talk about news that is that is actual
news this is just speculation here you
need to ask of all these people don't be
led by the nose what is your flash of
genius moment okay you say that you've
changed now what changed when did it
change and where were you when it
changed and i'd love to see you comment
below if you were a former liberal you
can comment below when your flash of
genius was or any really fundamental
life-altering decision i'd love to read
about but i know a lot of you used to be
liberals before you on the show we have
a lot of bernie supporters who kind of
came over after a while yeah so i'm
curious to see that and i would just
love that's the one thing i would like
to see from bill maher before we decide
to call off uh the dogs when i call off
the dogs i mean just show the clips to
you
so that you can judge them
for yourself as to whether they're funny
not that's always tough right when you
just go hey you know what we don't need
to edit anything just show the joke
that's worse than anything we could say
so i'm curious to see what you have to
say about that we're going to play
pokemon and racial so there's no way we
could do it on youtube and we also have
some more clips from bill maher uh
chastising pierce morgan that i want to
get to youtube we love you thank you uh
and we get it freest and fairest
election ever in uh history of course uh
the last election right 2020. sure
monkey pox is a pandemic
that means i don't really believe any of
that piss off youtube
you